welcome to mavis beacon teaches typing i
just have a few questions before we get
started
click ok when you are finished
why is it so tiny why is it it's teensy
tiny why is it so tiny what
i want to be 120 words hi i'm mavis
beacon i'm here to help you improve your
typing skills you can take a lesson
practice typing jump right into the fun
with a typing game or make another
selection from the menu
why is the music so loud it's so loud
welcome to the practice area
choose a practice passage from the list
or import your own documents to begin
remember your work in the practice area
won't be tracked in your progress
reports
autobiography autobiography of benjamin
franklin what what
[Music]
the
auto
biography of
why is it like this
uh what
i have ever had a pleasure in obtaining
any little uh
little anecdotes
of my ancestors
why is the music so loud done
[Music]
oh my god
all right man i'm going back home
[Music]
and make changes to your personal
profile
there we go so welcome to mavis beacon
teaches typing 2020. i'm assuming that a
lot of people bought this at the start
of kovid to get better at typing now the
reason that i am back here again is
number one to see how maybe speaking has
evolved over the years since the time of
my childhood when i used maybe
contagious typing seven but also
to help me win a war
to help me fight in the glorious arena
of combat to fend off the horns of
demons that will be
bursting down my door
and coming to rip me to threads in the
middle of the night i need to defend
myself with the only weapon that i have
which is my keyboard
i'm a keyboard warrior and i shall
drive off the hordes of the undead in a
different game that i'm going to go to
right now called
[Music]
[Laughter]
i can't type typing the dead so i don't
know if i've ever done a video on typing
of the dead i haven't exactly played it
too much myself but typing in the dead
is if you remember house of the dead the
arcade game you know
boom boom
arcade game they made a sega
why is everything opening in a window
now
why does nothing go full screen
is that necessaries i feel like this
might be
i feel like this might
feel like this might be a little
unnecessary
anyway
this is one
intermission i just got here
i'm trying to make a point here i'm
trying to be dramatique what's up
[ __ ]
isaac washington
make him mad and he'll rip your balls
off what is this
rated x okay i'm gonna play this
and then if i don't do well i'm gonna go
back to mavis beacon you know the temple
of training of typing so that i can
actually
get good you know what i mean
i don't like having capitals in here
halitosis
what in the hell mucus putrid sewage
trembler exalt oh i don't need to do
caps wha slow-mo
thankfully okay capitals are not
necessary
even though i am thinking about them a
lot so i have to press tab to be able to
get those bonuses
oh tab
loud noises
okay well this is a little silly and
slow
uh-huh
uh-huh
oh god uh it it
i can't even i don't even know what that
was
love and romance man mavis beacon you
really gotta help me oh now we eat
fatuous flattery
blue tits
a six minute steak what is so what is
any of this gamblers fallacy casting
call oh my god blubber nobody threatens
the ultimate sacrifice
freeze [ __ ]
because of the shocking nature of the
following scenes they are definitely not
recommended for the squeamish or the
easily offended
what
oh god is it boss fight time oh jasper
no
not so [ __ ] clever now are you i just
think this is silly
failed in the end failed in your end
teddy bear
okay
okay
oh damn we're dead
well
obviously i'm not good enough progress
will not be saved you know what i don't
deserve it
because
i'm not good enough
i need to go back and train
i need to go to my teacher to be able to
really truly be able to succeed in
typing of the day i need to go back to
mavis people wow it's loud again
you can take a lesson practice typing
welcome to the lesson area here you can
take a typing test to find out what
level typist you are or start at the
beginning of the lesson plan okay choose
an option to begin test my typing level
you're not going to read this to me
[Music]
start
oh sad fad the caps lock is on oh god
sad fad
flak ask fall fad sass
flash glass as hug egg reek lark
jug
feudal keel desk rude gel
toy wit opt quote quit
tight quad your way quay dozen verbal
verbal
wise and oxen zoom a
typewriter caught at
zorbiana grant test shows that you are a
beginning typist let's get started with
a few basic exercises and then move on
from there oh
really
really beginning typist i am offended i
did make a lot of errors let's learn
some new keys watch the guide i do can i
i really uh please i don't want to be
i don't want to be a can we try again
welcome back start the lesson
oh no
oh god okay
middle ring i actually do need to learn
that a little better i've always done
all those wrong with the ring i probably
should be better about that
okay
d
right okay
okay that a maybe i could get but maybe
i've been typing wrong my whoops maybe
i've been typing wrong my whole life i
really don't use
the correct keys that i should go and so
i i actually certain keys like period
and comma i don't have an instinctive
knowledge of what finger so i lose my
place a lot yeah that this is a good
point
c z
that is much easier if i do that wow
wow that is
that is a lot easier if i have a
dedicated finger to each of those
instead of trying to flip between both
of those with my
ring finger the entire time that is
better exceptional congratulations that
is better yeah that was actually a lot
better mavis you are an incredible
teacher and i have much to learn i will
be a better typer because of you
saves prejudge blued watches warmed
unbreathable
freed
ex-postulate colony savannah your
success is extraordinary you should be
proud of yourself i am proud of myself
thank you
try this con key combinations okay
picnic colonials probity peaks gouging
touch wood milestone penthouse enthrall
yeah i do mix up i mix up my fingers a
lot so my my fingers do cross a lot more
than i thought place your fingers over
the home road good old-fashioned saying
okay red
at night
sailors delight red sky in the morning
sailors
ah that should be pinky right i need to
look at this
warning
rain
oh that you want that with that hand i
guess that doesn't matter it's in
between
before
seven
fine
before
oh i did that weird
before i typed o with my middle finger a
weird
eleven
when the dew is on the grass
rain will never come ah did that one
weird too i type o with my middle why do
i do that
to
i never type with my pinky i do that
with my ring finger oh that's weird
you're doing a wonderful job keep up the
good work i needed to go back and
actually
learn some things last quiz as a
beginner if you pass this you'll move up
to intermediate i'm not ready
archery's
cantons that was better cast
away
madame
green
bags pampa with pinky ah that does flow
smoother
that with
ah
i don't do that or did
not
send
i have to rethink all of this
oh god i'm making steady progress with
every lesson oh no this one
versus the old one is giving me a lot
more to do here i actually want to do
more it's really oh my god i actually
don't know
this is weird intermediate level okay
uppercase keys oh my god
okay so shift m
shift p shift i
o
y with the finger there k
pinky with p
m
y
[Music]
oh this is actually throwing me off i'm
i i didn't realize this guys i didn't
realize that i was doing a lot of this
wrong which i am and i don't like that i
need to get back to the basics and
actually learn which fingers to use
because it does flow smoother how did i
get in this habit when i did maeve
speaking way back when i was a kid i was
doing it to what it said and it was
going better but over time it's been
years
so of course it's kind of slipped
no
north
nor
i'm just trying to make sure that i
actually do the correct ring finger p
with a pinky
p with pinky is not something i i ever
do i don't think but that does make it
go smoother poppy playtime
packy seth oh god i did it with ring
finger again
sore that was supposed to be i did that
with middle fingers supposed to be j
finger
that was an impressive performance it
really wasn't actually but i was trying
to get it what it should be pinky
patchwork
prevent
ted
culieri
[Music]
legislate
mercilessness
to the zombies non
permanent
up that's so much smoother if i do ring
pinky
mummy you're making steady progress with
every lesson
ah
new keys watch the guide and
press the t key okay t
oh right god that's the weirdest thing
when i have to do capital letters on the
right left hand side of keyboard i still
hit shift with my left hand but i just
put left pinky there i've never used
right shift but i should shouldn't i
it'd be faster i did that wrong i did it
with my pointer i need
q is
oh that's weird
s x oh don't do that
middle c interesting the weird thing is
it's not completely foreign to me right
it's like i must have learned this at
some point in this
way because it's coming back to me a lot
quicker
these fingers oh that's middle i'm not
doing that right i haven't done c right
okay maybe i'm not that's supposed to be
pointer
could
that's middle middle middle middle for c
middle
ring
you're making steady progress with every
lesson oh wow
mavis i had no idea
mrs beacon i did not know it's time for
a reward let's try again welcome
what is this put your typing skills to
the test
bridge
choose one on the list to get started
melia
can it knows that i need to do the seas
i don't know how oh god cans ah i'm not
even doing the shift right god i'm doing
the other side of the shift is i've
never done it that way
i don't know how i'm as fast as i am by
doing it
the way i've been doing it this is so i
can't describe it probably doesn't come
across but this is just bizarre i wish i
had a camera on my hands to show the
confusion of what's going on you know
what
okay so
this is now showing you why this is so
hard
so
duh
see my instinct is want to do that but
i'm supposed to do that with my middle
finger but i don't this is awkward to me
i usually do this for p which then
throws me off because my hand kind of
moves off of out of position that is
true
s-h-i-p
weird try that again
don't say my name here but you'd better
be quick the shark is right on your tail
what do you mean
oh god oh god
motif
geniality oh see i don't even know what
i did there everything went weird
in
slated
oh see what i do i shift in on the same
hand that's not right
subterraneous no that's not right it
should be these two not these two that
throws everything off pointer
middle
it is i do see the benefit of it
[Music]
no god i did that i need to do the other
side
okay
holy crap this is tough the music is
very fitting right now because
what the hell what the hell's going on
with me what the hell is going on with
my entire brain what what what happened
to me i've been a good typist all my
life but i do make a lot of errors all
the time and i think it's because my
hands are always flying all over the
place i'm quick but i'm inaccurate and
it's because my fundamentals are bad oh
my god
oh god no mavis no but i can get better
i can get better d
new this is new d
oh question mark f
interesting ah
oh weird hitting that with the pinky no
these are always my weakest the symbols
i've never learned them properly oh
that's pinky as well
weird
but that does flow smooth oh my god i
okay if i have everything in the same
spot i never have to look again
i feel like i'm back in school it's so
strange it feels like i'm just like i've
forgotten everything i've ever learned
and i have to go back
to the beginning why would you uh why
would but there are some things i don't
necessarily agree with because if i know
that the next one's going to be a an
exclamation why wouldn't i uh but you
know it does help to keep you balanced
that's what it does it's my desire to be
like well for this one it's good but it
does make me it so i have to look back
down make sure i'm in the right spot
again it does slow down i get that
because if i didn't have to check where
i was every time then i'd be able to
kill more zombies which is the whole
point
of why i'm doing this stop
oh
that's yeah that's completely backwards
from what i normally
the road is
dangerous
oh god why why have i given myself this
knowledge
to know how terrible i actually am but
symbols are getting better
symbols are getting better weirdly
enough
the symbols are getting better
[Music]
no pinky
[Music]
your success is extraordinary you should
be proud of yourself all right so this
is crazy because i have now realized
just how
poorly my typing discipline was for all
the speed in the world i've always had
plenty of errors because my hands have
to fly over and i have to look and
readjust all the time i don't actually
have a perfect muscle memory of
everything here so what i'm going to do
is i'm going to take this back
to the zombies
and i'm going to fight them again and
then i'm going to realize what my true
limitation is if i am able to do this in
the way that i should which is
discipline for the the characters that
are there
that is important and i didn't realize
how important i like my i cannot oversee
just how much my mind is unraveling at
the moment because of my sudden
realization that my actual typing
ability is nowhere near what it should
be because
i've been doing it wrong so many little
things doing it wrong that i see now
have caused me to like cause so many
errors i type every day and i do it
wrong and i just let myself get away
with it
but the good news is
that at the very least at the very least
there is a way forward that i will
become better than i ever have in my
life i will no more i will be able to do
more and my god
the ceiling
is unknown for how fast i can truly type
okay
so shift
it's not like everything i did well that
was wrong
because i shifted on the wrong side
fight
fight
i just need to make absolutely sure that
when i do these things i am using
the right
words
xenon xenon with that oh the ring finger
okay
lifeless
oh no i did that wrong
oh
i was never the zombie killer i thought
i was living a lie and okay what you may
be saying to yourself is oh it's okay
you are getting away with it
but i would have always been ceiling
with the the potential never fully
realized right i would have always had
this ceiling on my ability to type
with very limited improvement because
you can get good at something by doing
it slightly wrong you can get really
good
but it will never be as good as you
could be
if you actually did things correctly
because that would unlock so much i did
that wrong
middle finger i have to have the
discipline to
relearn these pieces i did that wrong
let me just
c h o p p e r i just gotta relearn
muscle memory that's what 20 something
years of me typing that i need to
relearn
my god
but i'm up to the challenge because it
is smoother and then my hands don't i
don't need to look down because i always
know where things are i can actually
memorize
where things are supposed to be
youth
is fleeting
don't uh you know how about you don't
oh this is so weird it's so weird it is
so weird
i
i'm not okay everybody
i i am not
okay
because now i'm rethinking everything
right i'm rethinking all of my letters
and i have to
pause because i'm i'm just like am i
correct am i
am i actually
doing this right
doing the other shift is so weird i've
literally never done that in my life
hey
or i've always done b with the other
hand the one that i'm not supposed to do
uh
uh yeah no i was like am i wrong i'm not
wrong i am right okay i'm good
i do feel feeble i feel feeble i can't
believe it
oh my god that's not right
okay oh i'm not even getting the
power-ups you know why because i don't
deserve them
oh my god i feel so i i'm gonna walk
away from this video feeling
terrible about myself and i do i feel
like i've been living a lie
my entire life i'm getting a little bit
faster but i need to make sure that i'm
not actually just slipping and going
back into my old style i'm using the
other shift
i'm doing things
as it should be i think
oh that c like c is really throwing me
because that's completely
i've said this so many times i'm
repeating myself
i wish i had never done this video
like i would have gone the rest of my
life been like i typed just fine
i type totally
adequately
everything's good the times that i'm
making mistakes are when i go back to my
old way you are dead i'm dead
oh my god
i have to do like a 12 hour livestream
of typing of the dead i have to because
this is the thing about me is when i
realize that i've been doing something
wrong or there is a problem i have to
fix it i have to
i just
i went into this being like ha ha i can
type good this will be fun people ask me
how fast i type i'll show you how fast i
type the truth of it is seems to be that
i don't type good at all
i type poorly i hit the backspace so
much that is a regular part of my entire
writing process is smashing that
backspace and not because like oh that's
i don't like what i wrote it's i make
errors almost every other word
i'm not okay
guess i'm not okay
this is not okay i now know that this is
going to be an obstacle in my life for
the next few months i'm going to be
thinking about this
i'm not joking this isn't playing up for
a bit i'm actually pissed off the thing
is like here's here's how i know it's
like when i'm typing like this like that
way i'm typing slower sure
my hands don't hurt as much
my fingers don't get tired as much
because the way that i type let me show
you let me show you what my hands are
doing when i am normally typing just the
way that i'm typing okay this is what i
normally do when i type and i'm gonna
try to just go
that's what i would do i would look down
and i would go yep that's right sure
[Music]
look how much my hands are moving all
over
the place i'm shifting just so i can
use my preferred fingers to be able to
do notice i i press y with the other
hand i don't know why
my hands go way off the
i do this
i don't know
already i'm trying to integrate some of
the things that i'm learning about the
quote-unquote correct way to do it well
not quote anymore
and it's slowing me down
oh this is good because i'm forgetting
how i did it before look how many times
i press the
oh my god don't look at me
oh no
oh
god oh no i've ruined everything
oh my god
i gotta go
i gotta go
i gotta go
i need to do a lot of thinking
and i need to maybe never type again
links in the description
to um
my podcasts
where i don't have to type and i just
talk
maybe i should just stick to that
i got a show
in space with markiplier
not much typing going on there
it's kind of better but you know i wrote
that thing
i wrote like 300 000 words total
all wrong of course you know i typed it
all wrong
[Music]
links are in the description but i can't
guarantee that i typed them
properly who could
all right i'm gonna go
see you bye
i gotta think about stuff i just have a
good day
type your comments with care but don't
think about it too much it'll ruin your
life
and the music stopped
good okay bye
[Music]
you